samedi le bar restaurant de noiset
n'avait pas encore levé commercialement
le rideau mais déjà les clients du
village afficha leur impatience de voir
cet établissement réouvrir ici tout a
été refait à neuf la salle bar la partie
restaurant et l'été deux terrasses pour
agrémenter le lieu en cours intérieur et
à l'extérieur derrière cette affaire il
y a ce quin génère un cuisinier qui
possède avec sa femme un restaurant à
tour nord le couple perd donc un trans
faire mais ici il sera locataire tout à
fait on va payer un loyer et le fond
sera à nous et avec une possibilité de
rachat des murs dans quelques années ce
qui pour nous fait quelque chose d'assez
d'assez important la partie mairie c'est
c'est effectivement l'achat et la
couverture et les les menuseries
extérieures et moi pour tout ce qui est
travaux ici j'ai j'en ai pour 130000 €
si la mairie de noiset a racheté les
lieux c'est que l'ancien restaurant
liquidation judiciaire avait été mise en
vente aux enchères mais pour un projet
immobilier pas question pour la mairie
de voir disparaître un nouveau commerce
municipalité et CCI ont donc bloqué la
procédure et la commune est devenue
propriétaire des murs depuis février
2012 on avait plus de restaurant plus de
postes plus de journaux plus de tabac la
actuellement on a une boulangerie qui
vient de fermer donc on a plus qu'une
épicerie qui fait un dépôt de pain en
attente mais c'est pour nous c'était
très important de reprendre ce
restaurant coout pour la municipalité
160000 €
ilutdu l' conse général un peu plus de
50000 € dans le cadre de son dispositif
à tout 37 dans le CRE de notre
dispositif àaucho 37 c'est plus de 2
million d'euros qui sont consacrés à
l'extension des entreprises et puis à
l'aide au dernier commerce dans les
communes rurales commune Conseil Général
des fonds publics qui ont permis à
noisette de retrouver son bar restaurant
mais ici pas encore d'offre multiservice
le patron n'a pas obtenu pour le moment
l'autorisation de vendre Press et
Française des jeux avec sa famille il
compte bien cependant s'appuyer sur une
clientèle fidèle FO dire est- que